let me say some anybody who's foolish
enough to threaten our family Mushu is
the spunky hilarious trickster dragon
that we all love from Disney's Mulan
he helps Mulan save China and he
restores honor to the family but what
would have happened if Mu Shu had
actually been a human rather than a
dragon we've got a few theories about
what would have gone down okay let's get
this show on the road tricky get the
bags let's move it
this sassy fast talking dragon has
captured the hearts of Disney fans all
over the world what's not to love
he's funny cute and definitely tells it
like it is and he's the best dragon
friend at girl disguised as a boy
soldier could ever ask for naturally we
are all wondering what moo shu would be
like if he were to take on a human form
not to worry we've got you covered we
found some human moo shu art that is
pretty impressive malfunctioning ami
posted this piece of moo shu as a human
under the category human disney animals
in this pic moo shu has red hair with a
blue fluff on top to represent the blue
horns of his dragon form he's wearing a
shirt with the dragon design on the back
which is a super nice touch we're not
sure if it's okay to say this but he's
actually kind of cute
but with that dramatic look in his eye
it seems he's lost some of the humour
we've all come to rely on from this
Disney character why so serious moo shu
this other version of human moo shu
shows moo shu as a human but he still
has the blue horns and floppy dragon
ears she added this artwork with a bit
of fan fiction in her story moo shu eats
an enchanted fortune cookie which turns
him into a human for three days she
describes his look saying that human moo
shu has bright red hair with a braid
that goes down to his shoulders with
some blonde strands of hair in the front
this artist managed to capture his humor
and mischievous nature but what would
have happened in the Disney version of
Mulan if mu shu had actually been human
let's explore some theories what would
human Moo shus personality be like in
the movie moo shu is a little dragon
with a big head he's a bit clumsy and
makes a lot of mistakes but he's doing
the best he can when we meet moo shu in
the film we find out that the dragon
used to be a guardian spirit for the
family unfortunately his guardian status
was revoked when he failed to protect a
family member Moo shus incompetence
resulted in that family
for losing his head ouch for fat dang
since the whole unfortunate incident
Mushu was demoted to the position of the
lowly incense burner and gangrene urn he
would only be in charge of ringing a
gong to wake of other capable guardians
of the family Lu Shu has been working to
re-establish his honour among the
ancestors so he is quite eager to please
when he fails at waking up the proper
Guardian to accompany Mulan he decides
he will join her on her journey and
maybe restore his status in the process
so if mu she was human how would that
affect his story would he be on the
small side the way he is in dragon form
if mu shu was human there's a good
chance he would be noticed by the
soldiers at the training camp so it's
possible that human moo shu would have
been wearing armor and fighting right
alongside Mulan he would definitely need
his own horse though because we know
what Mullins horse Khan thinks of him so
would ma she had been more helpful to
Mulan as a human or would he have made
bigger mistakes sure a human moo shu
would have done a better job in
personating the general's messenger but
he wouldn't have been able to bite the
rear ends off the men in the pond to
distract them when Mulan was bathing
keep watching if you want to find out
what Kahn would look like in his human
form could Mew shoe actually take on
human form when you look back at the
scene where the ancestors are gathering
that there is one important thing you
might notice it seems that while all the
ancestors our ghostly humans the
guardians are animals and mythological
creatures but from what we can see the
guardians consist of a dog an ox a
monkey a rooster a rabbit and of course
the great stone dragon they probably
symbolize the animals in the Chinese
zodiac
so can guardians ever be human because
well we're pretty sure there's no gear
of the human in the Chinese zodiac
so Moshe were to take on human form he
couldn't be a guardian he would have to
be either a deceased ancestor in Ghost
form or a human just like Mulan
that means Disney would have to rewrite
the whole film for it to make sense can
you imagine how different the movie
would have been if Mu Shu was just a
family friend sure he could fight
alongside her but then he wouldn't be
able to protect her the same way a
guardian could the whole ancestor /
guardian storyline would have been
eliminated
that was such a big part of the story
before everyone
of Milan's family members pray to the
ancestors at some point in the film this
seems to be a very important part of
their family heritage the film just
wouldn't be the same without it so the
only other alternative would be to allow
human moo shu to follow Mulan around in
Ghost form however he may not be much
help without you know a body it seems
that mushi was best equipped to help
move on in his current tiny dragon form
as long as he can dodge contours
how would Mulan and Moo shus
relationship be different if he were
human we already went through the
reasons why a human moo shu might not be
possible but let's have some fun and
pretend that it is if mu shu could be a
human in Mulan's world what kind of
relationship would they have when moo
shu first introduces himself to Mulan
he uses the good lusion of his shadow to
make himself appear far more impressive
and scary than he actually is but when
he comes out from behind the rock she
thinks he is just a little lizard really
the only thing he's got going for him is
the fact that he has a connection to
Mulan's ancestors when she slaps him
away he boldly states that great
dishonor will come to Mulan her horse
Khan who Mu Shu keeps calling the cow
and the whole family this makes Mulan
even more nervous and she agrees to let
him stay so without the whole dragon
Guardian ancestor thing it seems that
Mulan might not have had much time for a
human buddy at that moment she was quite
busy impersonating the man to fight for
the Chinese army in her father's place
and as far as any potential romance and
nobody got time for that
this girl is busy her schedule is packed
with learning how to get that arrow out
of the top of that super tall wooden
post
besides it's pretty clear that Mulan
quickly develops eyes for the leader of
the army troop we Shang Mu Shu would
probably be a tiny annoying dude with a
big mouth who is constantly getting move
on into trouble oh wait that's exactly
the relationship they have in the film
destroyed my palace and you have saved
us all would move on have saved China if
Mu Shu had been human so that we know
that as a tiny dragon mu she was able to
help Mulan save China from the hun army
he wasn't always perfect Khan wasn't his
biggest fan but between Lu Shu Khan and
Mulan's lucky cricket she was able to
use her wisdom cunning and fighting
skills to defeat Shanu Mu Shu was right
there to help light cannons save Mulan
from the Avalanche
and was somehow even able to impersonate
a soldier with urgent news from the
general another never seen a black hole
and during the final face-off between
Shan mu and Mulan Mu Shu was right there
with the firepower that she needed he
strapped a rocket to his back now that's
dedication so let's go through the list
of things that Mu Shu as a dragon can do
that Mu Shu as a human could not move
she was able to sneak into Mulan shirt
and traveled around with her undetected
what would be totally creepy if he tried
to do that as a human he could make her
happy porridge as a human or a dragon so
that's one thing that would stay the
same one thing that is a hundred percent
true though he would not have been able
to bite under water but as a human yuck
moo shu does have some pretty cool
abilities even if he is pocket-sized he
can fly he can breathe little tiny sized
fires and he has the ability to mobilize
neurons ancestors well except for the
great stone dragon
so without Mushu spine and
fire-breathing abilities Mulan would
have not been able to defeat Shan Yu on
the rooftop of the Emperor's Palace
Liu Shi would have been just another
ugly male concubines like the rest of
her soldier pals let's face it
although Mu Shu wasn't the perfect
Guardian she needed him and she
definitely would have not been able to
save China without him I'm working on it
ton while we're on the subject let's
talk about Khan move on horse the direct
translation of Khan needs prints but it
can also mean king or leader what kind
of been royalty if he was human so if he
were human could he have been
romantically connected to Milan fans
seem to think so which is why they've
posted some human interpretations of
Khan on the Internet
this is what deviant artists chaco
thinks Khan would have looked like and
this is what human con would look like
according to daxter pass attacks another
artist plays mate even drew human con
with a piece of grass in his mouth so
that's impressive so who would you vote
for
Mushu or con Mushu and Connor both loyal
friends and crucial members of Mulan's
team but the thing that makes me shoe
standout is his tenacity this little guy
never gives up no matter how impossible
the circumstances may be
Mulan's family is very important to him
it seems obvious that Mulan and Mu Shu
have a true bond
by the end of the first movie Mushu
seems like a very lucky dragon
so wouldn't really matter if he was a
dragon or a human it seems that he would
always find a way to help me lon
no matter what form he took he was
determined to always have her back and
he could always make her laugh which
it's hard to do when you're in the
middle of fighting a war to save your
entire country so even if Mushu was a
human a dog a monkey a rabbit a rooster
or a dragon he would have done anything
for Mulan and her family overall it's
clear that moo shu would have been a
good friend Mulan no matter what what do
you think with my stupid tyranny habits
pageants
how would this story have been different
if mu shu and khan had been human
instead of animal sidekicks i'm
travel-size to your convenience if i was
my real size your cow here with that
fright down Bisset hit us up in the
comments with your theories
don't break it to subscribe to the
things and hit the notification bell to
be the first to see our latest videos
thanks for watching and see you next
time
[Music]